ABCs of AI T is for Transformers
Transformers or Transformer models are a
type of neural network that were
developed in 2017 by Google researchers
the paper attention is all you need was
published and propos Transformers to
solve the problem of sequence
transduction AKA transforming inputs
into outputs this reduced the heavy and
timeconsuming training overhead
previously required and ushered in the
new era of AI think of tasks like speech
recognition machine translation and
question answering many models today use
the Transformer architecture remember
that short I did about Bert the T stands
for Transformers and is used in Google's
chatbot bar and there are some other
popular chat BS that you may have heard
of that also has a te in the name that
stands for Transformers Deep Mind Made a
massive breakthrough in predicting
protein structures by harnessing the
power of Transformers check out more
about this breakthrough in the long
video linked under the title see you
next time on